[Musique]
le bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition spéciale proposée par la
rédaction de tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi
29 octobre voici les titres un nouveau
confinement pour quatre semaines minimum
c'est la réponse d'emmanuel macron pour
freiner la deuxième vague de colis 19
les déplacements réduit au strict
minimum et muni d'une attestation et les
écoles collèges et lycées resteront
ouverts le télétravail renforcer invité
tout à l'heure le docteur frédérique
prud'homme le prg et président de
l'ordre des médecins des yvelines et
didier baichère députés du département
le confinement des buts cette nuit à
zéro heure ce vendredi les yvelinois
donc pu se rendre encore aujourd'hui
dans certains commerces non essentiels
qui vont fermer au restaurant est chez
le coiffeur notamment nous revivrons
cette dernière journée nous serons
également depuis le péage de buchelay
sur l'a13 pour voir si les franciliens
migrent vers la normandie pour ce
confinement
et puis comment cette nouvelle annonce
est elle accueillie par les habitants et
élus du territoire réponse à suivre et
nous parlerons tout à l'heure d'un autre
sujet d'actualité
la grippe avec des vaccins qui sont en
pénurie en ce moment c'est une journée
est très angoissante qu'ont vécu les
français ce jeudi en plus des début
imminent d'un nouveau confinement est la
menace terroriste a ressurgit
brutalement seulement deux semaines
moins de deux semaines après
l'assassinât de samuel pâti à conflans
sainte honorine un homme abattu en
avignon qui voulait attaquer des
policiers au couteau un autre individu
armé arrêté à lyon et cet attentat au
couteau à la basilique notre dame à nice
qui a fait trois morts et plusieurs
blessés ce matin le plan vigipirate a
été portée au niveau urgence attentats
en france ce jeudi à sartrouville cette
grande opération de police en début
d'après midi près de l'église
saint-martin finalement sans conséquence
un jeune homme a été interpellé suspecté
de vouloir commettre un acte terroriste
c'est le père de l'individu qui a alerté
les autorités après que son fils lui ai
confié vouloir je cite faire comme à
nice avant de quitter son domicile
l'homme visiblement fichier est ce
n'était finalement pas armés comme
certaines rumeurs la firme est sa
voiture fouillé par les démineurs et
aucun explosif n'a été découvert à son
bord après avoir été interrogé le
suspect a été finalement relâchés par
les forces de l'ordre et par précaution
le quartier pavillonnaire
et du plateau attenant à l'église saint
martin avaient été évacués au cours de
la journée
après avoir consulté les scientifiques
dialoguer avec les forces politiques
économiques et sociales
après avoir échangé aussi avec tous nos
partenaires européens et peser le pour
et le contre
j'ai décidé qu'il fallait retrouver à
partir de vendredi
le confinement qui a stoppé le virus
emmanuel macron a donc annoncé le début
d'un nouveau confinement il débute cette
nuit l'objectif affiché protéger les
plus fragiles les plus jeunes les
soignants elle est plus modeste et
l'économique est ce que va changer
concrètement ce confinement ont fait le
point avec eléonore sinoquet ce
confinement numéro 2 sera plus souple
mais il ne faut pas se tromper ce sera
bien un confinement
emmanuel macron a donc annoncé qu'il
serait applicable dans la nuit de jeudi
à vendredi
c'est à dire ce soir à minuit et ce pour
une durée de quatre semaines jusqu'au
1er décembre
alors concrètement ce qui va changer par
rapport au premier confinement du
printemps dernier ce sont les écoles
collèges et lycées qui vont rester
ouverts les crèches elles aussi vont
continuer à accueillir les enfants
toutefois un protocole strict et
renforcée devrait être mise en place
la rentrée est de toute façon prévu
lundi 2 novembre le premier ministre
jean castex a aussi annoncé aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée nationale que les enfants
dès 6 ans devront porter le masque
obligatoirement en ce qui concerne les
universités et les grandes écoles pour
elle c'est la fermeture des cours en
visioconférence et à distance devront
être mis en place partout où ce sera
possible pour nos déplacements le
président a confirmé les rumeurs comme
au printemps ils seront limités à
certains motifs aller au travail chez le
médecin sortir son chien se rendre pour
aider des personnes vulnérables faire
ses courses
c'est le retour de l'attestation
obligatoire pour sortir de chez soi
elle devrait être disponible d'ici peu
ce soir ou demain sur le site du
gouvernement également terminé les
déplacements entre régions une certaine
souplesse sera normalement accordée ce
week-end notamment pour les retours de
vacances de la toussaint les commercial
commentaire quant à eux restent bien
évidemment ouvert ce qui change par
rapport au printemps dernier ce sont les
administrations mairies préfectures dur
poste ou encore pôle emploi vont rester
ouverts au public
également le secteur du btp n'est pas
concerné par la fermeture les chantiers
devraient se poursuivre enfin les
maisons de retraite ehpad restent elles
aussi ouvertes pour éviter je cite les
drames humains et pour les autres
commerces le couperet est lui tombé
c'est tout ce qui est non essentiels est
fermée à compter de ce soir comme les
bars les restaurants ou encore les
coiffeurs mais le président s'est voulu
rassurant il a émis l'hypothèse d'une
réévaluation d'ici quinze jours pour de
possibles et assouplissement de cette
mesure
pour ce qui est du week-end de la
toussaint quelques exceptions tout de
même les fleuristes par exemple tout
comme les cultes et les cimetières
pourront rester ouverts pour finir les
rassemblements sont évidemment interdit
que ce soit en extérieur mais aussi à
l'intérieur
le président a précisé que les réunions
privées étaient exclues et je précise
que des précisions seront apportées par
le premier ministre jean castex qui doit
s'exprimer à partir de 18h30 ce soir
pour réagir à cette actualité deux
invités avec moi en plateau le docteur
frédérique prud'homme bonsoir bonsoir
président de l'ordre des médecins des
yvelines et par téléphone didier
baichère bonsoir bonsoir
la députée la république en marche des
yvelines de la première circonscription
des yvelines j'en profite didier
baichère de vous avoir pour vous faire
réagir aussi à cette actualité du jour
l'actualité a lié au terrorisme cet
attentat ce matin en la basilique notre
dame de nice qui a fait trois morts une
minute de silence à d'ailleurs été
observée en par les députés à
l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui le premier ministre jean
castex s'exprimer devant les députés il
était présent pour cette minute de
silence
plusieurs attaques ont été également
déjoué à lyon en avignon on apprend
aussi à cette actualité finalement une
fausse alerte
à sartrouville la france est plus que
jamais visé par la menace terroriste
quelle est votre réaction après cette
journée très anxiogène oui une tension
qui avec près maintenant l'occasion d'en
parler en plateau la semaine dernière
quand vous tapez tapez à
conflans-sainte-honorine
c'est donc le conneries le pasteur en
tâtant h c etc
très concrètement pour un peu rassuré
c'est le passage avec la force
sentinelle de 3000 soldats à 7000 col
bat sur le terrain qui vont surveiller
de manière intensive mais que l'ex culte
des écoles tous les lieux sensibles dans
notre département et j'ai vu tout à
l'heure un message très clair adressé
par le creps à l'ensemble des élus des
collectivités locales pour renforcer
l'ensemble de la collaboration entre les
forces de police et le puy liste
municipale pour s'assurer que tout le
monde puisse le pasteur les semaines qui
viennent avec le plus de tranquillité
possible donc on va tous vigilants et
est vrai que c'était une journée
particulière à l'assemblée nationale ce
matin
en votant à la fois du réseau unitaire
de soutien au gouvernement pour ce
deuxième confinement et en même temps
faisant au même moment une minute de
silence par rapport à d'autres je vais
demander juste à la technique si on peut
avoir un peu plus de retour en plateau
pour la suite de votre interview on a
compris votre réponse didier baichère
mais c'est pour qu'on puisse aussi bien
comprendre la suite de l'interview je
précise que plan vigipirate a été portée
au niveau urgence a tenté avec le
président de la république a d'ailleurs
annoncé que 3000 à 7000 militaires
allaient être déployés sur le sol
français
cette actualité aussi un qui fait la une
aujourd'hui c'est la france et les îles
une qui vont donc s'apprêter à être re
confiné pour freiner la deuxième vague
du coronavirus les projections parle de
9000 patients qui seront en réanimation
en novembre une vague donc plus violente
qu'au printemps on voit s'afficher aussi
les chiffres dans les yvelines et qui ne
sont pas bons ils sont sur une pente
ascendante vertigineuse depuis plusieurs
jours dr prud'homme re confiner les
français ce que c'était la bonne
décision à prendre peut-être là l'ultime
aussi décision à prendre
je ne sais pas si c'est la bonne mais de
toute façon c'était la seule qu'on
pouvait prendre actuellement entre et un
couvre-feu qui n'avait pas fait la
démonstration de son efficacité
alors peut-être qu'on aurait pu attendre
un petit peu si le virus nous avait
laissé la possibilité d'attendre mais je
crois que les conditions sanitaires ne
le permettait pas et les présidents de
la république avec tous les conseils
qu'il a autour de lui
a pris une décision qui est difficile
difficile parce qu'il faut trouver le
bon équilibre entre protéger les la
population et puis d'un autre côté ne
pas arrêter l'économie et trouver ce
juste équilibre et quelque chose à mon
avis de très difficile didier baichère
en parler du confinement comme la
dernière solution la dernière chance la
solution de la dernière chance est ce
que c'était inévitable au vu de
l'accélération de l'épidémie
ces derniers jours oui je pense que
malheureusement on ne pouvait pas
continuer à se poser cette question en
permanence entre l' équilibre entre
l'attenté où ils économique il faut
arriver à gérer les deux moi je
regardais puisque chaque semaine nous
avons une réunion de coordination avec
la rnt la préfecture l'ensemble des
débuts et quand on a vu la semaine
dernière les chiffres qui battait d'un
taux d'occupation d'élus dans les
minimes taux d'occupation par des
patients colvin de 50% à 70% en une
seule semaine on voyait bien que
l'accélération était beaucoup trop forte
pour attendre les effets peut être
positif on ne fait pas du du couvre-feu
et on a perdu
didier baichère en tout cas je précise
que les députés ont apporté une large
majorité leur soutien à cette nouvelle
mesure du confinement je le disais tout
à l'heure jean castex exprimé devant les
députés
ce matin alors c'est une décision aussi
qui a fait beaucoup réagir je vais vous
redonner la parole didier baichère dans
un instant dans la sphère politique
regardez ce tweet de la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse le gouvernement
donne le sentiment de courir après la
pandémie la deuxième vague aurait dû
être anticipé ça c'est les mots de
valérie pécresse dans ce tweet pour
l'ancien député des yvelines qui je le
rappelle est toujours élu au sein de la
commune de vélizy villacoublay
leur confinement c'est tout simplement
l'aveu de l'échec de la stratégie du
gouvernement d'après le président du
sénat gérard larcher
écoutez le il était l'invité ce matin de
nos confrères de lci
il faut que nous tenions tous un langage
de richmond fiabilité mais il faut
donner à espérer
et donner à espérer c'est je dois le
dire donner le sentiment qu'on a tiré
les leçons de la première vague je pas
tout à fait certain qu'on les ait encore
totalement tiré et il se préparait à
vivre avec le mien au fond la décision
d'hier et démontre l'échec de la
proposition on va vivre avec le virus
non on voit bien qu'on ne peut pas vivre
on ne peut pas vivre en tous les cas
dans des conditions quasi normal avec le
virus est une réaction qui était chez
nos confrères de ces news didier
baichère est-ce que vous qu'est ce que
vous en pensez à 2,7 de cette
explication gérard larcher est ce que
c'est un aveu d'échec pour vous du
gouvernement le fait de replacer la
france la france en confinement si on
tient un langage de responsabilité je
crois que c'est très peu opportun de
faire de la politique en ce moment et je
suis je dois dire parfaitement attristé
par les propos du rar larcher ou ceux de
valérie pécresse
vous savez les commentateurs d'un côté
ceux qui agitent moi quand je le vois
que nous avons passés de 5,8 à dix
villes et la capacité hospitalière quand
je vois que nous sommes passés avec les
nouveaux respirateur depuis 7000
personnes qui vont être accueillies en
réanimation à 30 milles en france nous
sommes dans l'action et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement personne
ne peut contrôler cette pandémie la
prédire et c'est ça qui est extrêmement
difficile mais nous nous sommes au
travail au quotidien et nous sommes là
pour trouver des solutions pour pour les
français et nous évoluons avec cette
maladie chaque semaine et nous prenons
les décisions pour que la france puisse
se tenir debout
aussi bien socialement qu économiquement
votre avis dr prud'homme est ce que ça
témoigne d'un échec cette solution
finalement c'était aussi une décision
courageuse à prendre puisque on parlait
de cette solution comme une solution
vraiment la dernière chance tout déficit
toute décision est difficile à prendre
et moi je ne fais pas de politique je
suis médecin
nous ce qu'on regarde c'est pas ce qui
s'est passé avance et on regarde ce
qu'on doit faire maintenant est comment
on peut préparer l'avenir et je crois
que je peux des leçons qu'on doit
retenir c'est il faut qu'ils aient une
meilleure association entre la ville et
l'hôpital et dans le 78 c'est ce qu'on
est en train de travail
et c'est de regarder comment on peut
éviter que la majorité des malades
aillent se faire hospitaliser qu'elles
puissent être pris en charge à domicile
et c'est le travail que nous fournissons
je pense que très rapidement dans les
jours qui suivent en coordination bien
sûr avec la rs avec les hospitaliers
avec la ville
nous coordonnons les éléments pour que
le maximum de patients puissent être
pris en charge dans les meilleures
conditions possibles à domicile et c'est
ça le plus important pour décharger un
peu l'hôpital de cet afflux et pour
pouvoir gérer cette crise je vous pose
la question à vous et je ferai aussi
réagir didier baichère sur ce sujet
c'est un confinement qui est quand même
on va dire un peu plus léger que la
dernière fois avec notamment les écoles
les collèges les lycées qui reste ouvert
est ce que vous craignez pas qu'ils
aient eux mêmes des foyers de
contamination ce qu'on a pu voir des
contaminations qui se déroulait dans
dans le milieu scolaire que ces foyers
de contamination demeure alors réputé et
toutes les études semblent le montrer
que en dessous de 6 ans le risque de
contamination est quand même
relativement faible et qu'entre six et
11 ans eh bien peut-être que le port du
masque peut être recommandée et et je
crois que ça serait bien sachant que je
pense que ça peut être acceptée par ses
enfants et qui le garderont au maximum à
partir du moment où les bien expliqué et
les professeurs puissent prendre en
charge correctement les les enfants et
ça d'ailleurs été annoncée ce matin par
jean castex que le max le masque le port
du masque serait obligatoire à partir de
6 ans en école primaire il fallait que
ce soit le cas didier baichère que ces
écoles puissent rester ouverte
quand on a fait l'analyse de ce qui
s'était passé pendant la première étape
du confinement qui pensent qu'il faut
dire la vérité nous avons nous avons
perdu entre 15 et 25 % d'élèves suivant
les cas contribution du département des
yvelines pour plein de raisons parce que
l'équipement informatique n'était pas là
peut-être la connexion internet n'était
pas bonne et puis tout simplement
peut-être aussi la surpopulation parfois
dans l'habitation qui peuvent être de
l'enfant ne pouvait pas suivre
l'enseignement et puis tu appelles
d'école on puisse faire de la plante de
l'enseignement à 80 par un professeur se
sont beaucoup mobilisés d'autres moins
donc nous ne pouvions pas dans une
nouvelle phase de confinement de
permettre à nouveau d'avoir des enfants
des jeunes d'adultes qui n'aille pas à
l'école et qui sacrifie quelque part
l'avenir de la société dont il est
essentiel d'avoir gardé l'entente de
l'éducation nationale sur le pont
ouverte pour l'enseignement merci didier
baichère d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
début d'éditions spéciales la boue je
rappelle que vous êtes député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
la dr prud'homme rester avec nous tu
qu'on parle tout à l'heure d'une autre
actualité la pénurie de vaccins contre
la grippe
allez une autre réaction politique à
vous proposer à présent on parlait du
port du masque qui sera obligatoire pour
les élèves des six ans en école primaire
c'est une décision qui a provoqué la
colère du maire de trappes à lire ah bah
écoutez le la situation sanitaire et je
peux le confirmer a été donné sur trappe
s'aggrave considérablement ces dernières
semaines tout avait été nous dit on
préparé pour éviter un second
confinement c'est donc là un constat
d'échec est assez claire de la faire de
la politique du gouvernement
il ya un point qui me met en colère en
tant que maire c'est de découvrir ce
matin par la presse que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et le gouvernement
impose aux écoliers de 6 à 11 ans de
porter le masque à l'école et je
constate que plus de six mois plus tard
nous sommes incapables d'alerter les
élus locaux de mobiliser les services
publics et donc la ville de trappes
comme beaucoup de villes de france le
maire que je suis se retrouvent
aujourd'hui à courir après les masques
pour pouvoir fournir des masques aux
familles ne pas le laisser seul face à
cette nouvelle obligation que l'on
apprend par la presse
un jeudi matin à deux jours de la
rentrée scolaire ne suis vraiment
atterré de ce niveau de désorganisation
le confinement donc décrété de nouveau
jusqu'au 1er décembre une période que
s'apprête à revivre les yvelinois
quelles réactions au lendemain des
annonces des manuels macron regarder les
réponses de ces quelques habitants
collectées par mélanie poker et célia
gars de 100 go
je pense que c'était une agréable toute
façon il fallait bien qu'on passe par là
je pense pour que l'épidémie retombe
maintenant à voir les retombées dans
quatre semaines voir si vraiment c'est
efficace chez une bonne chose et pas
pour l'économie comme tous les virus
il faut atteindre l'immunité collective
et que tout ce que l'on fait ne ne
servira nous servira strictement à rien
que je suis hospitalière traiter la
problématique c'est que tant qu'on
n'aura pas trouvé un vaccin efficace
ça peut durer ça peut être pérenne
pendant des mois j'espère pas des années
et je trouve que ça ne peut pas aller
assez loin
quand on voit ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans toute l'europe
j'ai pas d'avoir peur à tout donner pour
me toucher
je pars d'un temps on attend les
consignes de l'université qui nous
envoient des mails à chaque fois n'est
pas ça on n'a pas d'info donc on sait
pas comment ça se passait à d'autres
réactions politiques à vous proposer
celle de laurent morin à présent
responsable départemental du
rassemblement national dans les yvelines
pour lui le président emmanuel macron
n'a pas assez anticipé cette deuxième
vague il était au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
je pense que les français
ne font plus confiance à emmanuel macron
il y a également le fait que emmanuel
macron le 14 juillet avait annoncé qu'
il serait prêt pour la deuxième vague
or il a dit hier dans son allocution
qu'il était totalement submergé je crois
qu'il a prononcé ce mot de submerge de
submersion de ce une île qu'ils étaient
submergés
donc le gouvernement est submergé
emmanuel macron est submergé il prend
des décisions erratique sans informer
spécialement sont en position hier une
réunion ou avant-hier avaient eu avec
lui une réunion entre le gouvernement et
les responsables de l'opposition tous
les responsables de leur position quelle
que soit leur place sur l'échiquier
politique sont ressortis de cette
réunion outre et par l'absence de
concertation par l'absence d'information
donc on al impression qu emmanuel macron
prend les décisions
quasiment seul avec son son conseil
scientifique
une décision d'une très grande prudence
c'est la vie en revanche de joséphine
coleman ce berger la mère de plaisir à
depuis l'annnonce échangé avec
différents commerçants installés dans la
commune et relancer aussi un
accompagnement des personnes âgées et
fragiles déjà mises en place lors du
premier confinement elle était
interrogée par mélanie poker c'est que
des tables d'organisation se met en
place et on va bien sûr accompagné tous
à des mises en place pour que les angles
et les commerces qui pourront le faire
face des actions à domicile puis se
faire du portage haussier à domicile
pourquoi pas des interventions à
domicile dans la possibilité de nous on
va être on va être non seulement porter
de communication d'information pour ça
mais également accompagnateurs si on
peut aider
l'important vous savez bien sûr sans les
commerces où l'avait dit bien sûr sans
les entreprises mais sont aussi des
personnes âgées les personnes isolées
les personnes fragiles qui sont chez
elles et donc toute notre chaîne de
solidarité va se remettre en place est
une chaîne de solidarité de portage de
repas bien sûr mais aussi de portage de
course
et puis d'accompagnement psychologique
aussi des personnes via le téléphone ou
via du présentiel quand c'est nécessaire
le confinement en débutent donc cette
nuit à vendredi vendredi à zéro heure il
sera interdit de sortir de chez soi sans
motif valable pour les yvelinois ce
jeudi 29 octobre a permis de
de profiter des derniers instants dans
plusieurs commerçants l'essentiel
contraint de fermer un dernier
restaurant une dernière coupe de cheveux
reportage de nicolas landry michael et
demi d'euros patrick jacques de dixmude
et astrid bergère comme un air de déjà
vu dans les grandes surfaces les clients
sont venus en nombre dès 10 heures ce
matin les allegrouillez de chariots les
rayons se vident et est latente aux
caisses s'allonger alors que les risques
de pénurie alimentaire sont minimes
ils font partie des sociétés dans
l'obligation de fermer leurs portes les
salons de coiffure ont fait le plein de
clients ce matin la dernière chance de
renouveler sa chevelure avant le
confinement
j'avais réservé déjà parce que c'était
nécessaire ça faisait trois mois que
j'étais parler mais bon
j'ai bien fait l'un dans l'autre je
crois qu'après c'est bouclé je fais
partie des clients privilégiés oui parce
que j'ai pris mon rendez vous au juste à
temps face à cette sur demande la
gérante de cette entreprise s'est
organisé le salon fermera à 21h au lieu
de 19h 4 coiffeuse sont mobilisés elles
attendent près de 20 clients chacune
pour la journée c'est un 24 décembre
aujourd'hui inattendu on n'était pas
préparé à ça on a déployé tout ce qui
était possible de faire pour que la
journée fonctionne bien
celle qui était en vacances sont revenus
celles qui étaient en repos sont venus
aussi porter main forte
même situation dans les restaurants dans
cet établissement dans l'hyper centre de
montigny le bretonneux c'est le dernier
service de midi classique avant
plusieurs semaines de fermeture
une déception pour les habitués fermer
mes petits restaurants préférés là où on
mange très bien on est très bien
accueilli c'est scandaleux
ça va nous manquer je trouve cette
décision ridicule mais bon on s'y pliant
contraint et forcé tu me dis nous serons
complets on a une grosse pour moi on a
justement de la vente à emporter
ce soir on a également des réservations
et dès demain donc dès demain nous
ouvrons d'établissement uniquement pour
la vente à emporter la libre est une
adaptation incontournable pour ce
restaurant ouvert en février 2020 et
comme lors du premier confinement les
franciliens vont t'ils s'exiler vers la
province on a vécu encore aujourd'hui
une journée record en termes de bouchons
en ile-de-france direction tout de suite
la barrière de péage de buchelay sur
l'autoroute a13 retrouver astrid bergère
bonsoir quelle est la situation sur
place
oui je me trouve donc à la barrière de
péage de buchelay ici le trafic très
chargé
il ya beaucoup de véhicules dans les
deux sens mais ce n'est pas propre aux
yvelines dans toute l'île de france on
observe la même chose c'est un record à
18 heures il n'y avait plus de 700 km de
bouchons cumulés
alors on ne sait pas si ce sont des
personnes qui quittent l'île de france
pour se confiner ailleurs ou si ce sont
des personnes qui rentrent de vacances
mais le président de la république a
rappelé qu'une certaine souplesse ce
serait serait appliquée pour le retour
des vacances de la toussaint
merci astrid berges heures depuis la
barrière de péage de buchelay sur
l'autoroute a13 voilà ce que l'on peut
vous dire ce soir sur cette actualité le
confinement qui débute dans la nuit à
vendredi vendredi à zéro heure en france
et dans les yvelines demain à retrouver
aussi une nouvelle édition spéciale
vendredi donc à 18h sur cette actualité
avec réaction conséquences aussi pour le
monde du sport le monde de la culture en
invités notamment monseigneur bruno
valentin évêque auxiliaire de versailles
qui parlera de la menace terroriste qui
pèse sur la communauté chrétienne en
plein week-end de la toussaint
l'autre actualité que nous allons
développer à présent avec le docteur
frédérique prud'homme qui est toujours
avec moi en plateau c'est la pénurie
actuelle de vaccins contre la grippe
avec l'épidémie de colis de 19 de
nombreuses personnes souhaitent cette
année se faire vacciner problème
infirmiers ainsi que pharmacien
yvelinois font face à une potentielle
pénurie deux semaines seulement après le
lancement du de la campagne de
vaccination ce sujet regardez ce sujet
de bixente mais rien senti steban et
d'eléonore sinoquet
depuis le 13 octobre dernier la campagne
de vaccination contre la grippe a débuté
dans les pharmacies une année
particulière compte tenu des
circonstances sanitaires il ya beaucoup
plus de demandes que d'habitude on a des
plages horaires qui sont très rempli
rapidement pour privilégier les
personnes qui ont des pathologies
chroniques des personnes de plus de 65
ans on va avoir du mal à à proposer les
vaccins des personnes qui n'ont pas de
pathologies chroniques pour choeur de
rupture de stock en fait dans cette
pharmacie de montigny le bretonneux
l'équivalent d'un mois de ventes de
vaccins des autres années a été
distribué la première semaine
pourtant il est uniquement donner aux
personnes à risque nous on a eu des
consignes claires du de la part des
agences régionales de santé nous
demandant de prioriser la vaccination
sur les personnes qui étaient sur les
populations à risque donc les personnes
pour lesquelles la sécurité sociale a
envoyé un bon de vaccination
contrairement aux autres années où on
est obligé de sensibilité les les
personnes à l'importance de la
vaccination grippale cette année c'était
plutôt le contraire on devait freiner
les les personnes qui se ruaient en
pharmacie pour acheter des quantités
importantes de vaccins les soignants
appelle à ne pas sous-estimer l'épidémie
grippale et déplorent ne pas pouvoir
vacciner tout le monde
pour moi c'est nécessaire de se vacciner
parce que la grippe saisonnière tue on a
dû refuser le refuser les ventes de ce
vaccin ou à la population normale qui
souhaitaient se vacciner et je rappelle
que la vaccination est importante
également pour
les personnes qui sont pas forcément
fragile seulement deux semaines après le
début de la campagne 70 à 80% des
pharmacies non plus de stock
elles attendent les prochaines
livraisons prévues pour début novembre
un docteur prudemment l'a entendue dans
ce sujet près de 80 pour cent des
pharmaciens n'ont plus de stocks est ce
qu a votre avis on peut parler de
pénurie ou finalement c'est juste une
précipitation en ce début de campagne de
vaccination je pense que pour l'instant
c'est simplement une rupture de stock
chaque année nous incitons la population
à se vacciner
on est souvent pas très entendus et
cette année avec les l'histoire du coc
vide
tout le monde a compris l'utilité d'une
vaccination et notamment sur la grippe
ce qu'il ya ce qu'il faut penser qu' il
ya une population prioritaire
elle a reçu des bons de la part de
l'assurance maladie faut d'abord laisser
ces patients se faire vacciner
et après ça sera offert au reste de la
population je crois que c'est une
quelque chose de raisonnable ça c'est
raisonnable et c'est aussi primordial
pour éviter d'engorger les services d
urgence qui est sont déjà très
grandement a impacté par le corps d'un
virus exactement il faut éviter que on
attrape la grippe et seul le vaccin
permet de le faire et donc en vaccinant
le maximum de personnes
on évitera d'engorger effectivement les
urgences et mais il faut rappeler que la
grippe est aussi pris en charge par la
médecine libérale et ne pas oublier que
les aigrinois peuvent toujours avoir
accès à leur médecin pour toutes leurs
autres pathologies
il faut pas oublier de continuer à se
faire soigner pour les autres
pathologies
ça c'est important de le rappeler vous
vous êtes peur qui est peut-être une
surmortalité alors que finalement il ya
une conséquence il ya ce colis de 19
avec les autres pathologies
effectivement lors de la première vague
de tout s'est un peu arrêté et la
population a eu peur de venir consulter
pour leur consultation habituelle je
crois que c'est une erreur
tout le monde s'est organisé pour les
recevoir avec des filières qui sont
maintenant bien sécurisé et je crois
qu'il faut continuer à se faire suivre
pour ses autres pathologies ça me paraît
fondamental si on en revient au vaccin
contre la grippe a ce qu on peut
rappeler qu'ils sont les personnes juste
en prioritaire
rex 1 elles sont d'abord elles ont
toutes reçu un bon de l'assurance
maladie mais c'est essentiellement les
gens qui ont plus de 65 ans et puis ceux
qui ont des pathologies chroniques
hypertension diabète on retrouve un peu
toujours les mêmes pathologies à risque
pour le coc vidé pour la grippe pour
tout ce qui est virale et il ya aussi
des gestes barrières dans le cadre aussi
de la grippe sont les mêmes finalement
que ce pur pour la colline oui j'espère
qu'on va apprendre chaque année une fois
que le coït sera passée à éviter aussi
ces épisodes de grippaux je pense que le
masque se laver les mains et garder une
des sensations quand on est
symptomatique me paraît fondamental et
on est en train de l'apprendre
est ce que finalement de cette période
un peu négative où vous le dit voilà on
apprend des gestes barrière vous porter
le masque sur ce plateau mais c'est
aussi tout simplement se se laver les
mains que vous avez bon espoir que ça
limite peut être à l'avenir la
transmission d'autres d'autres
pathologies d'autres virus a je crois
qu'on apprend au fur et à mesure et que
ça ça restera dans les mémoires
au moins pour un certain temps merci
d'être venus en plateau le docteur
frédérique prud'homme je rappelle vous
êtes le président de l'ordre des
médecins des yvelines merci d'avoir est
avec vous tout au long de cette édition
spéciale qui touche à sa fin merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant on va
essayer de retrouver à tout de même le
sourire en cette période anxiogène de
cette fuite loisirs avec cellier agathe
son go qui va vous dirai oui c'est
possible
comment célébrer halloween à domicile
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
non